[Music]
see we have a sort of a situation here
joanna and i didn't just meet in hawaii
we spent a good deal of time together
i mean all the time uh after we met
and well we have this problem
i fell in love with your daughter
and as incredible as it may seem
she fell in love with me
and we flew back to san francisco to see
if you or mrs stratton would have any
objections if we got married
why was my black card to see you so
concerned about us minority folks
oh come on chef what is with this black
huh you ain't so black
and you ain't so white baby
until you do right by me everything you
think about is going to crunch
don't do it missy don't trade places
with what i've been doing
let's go to the car he ain't worth it
he ain't worth it
so you say you can have a woman who'll
obey you every command
but you'd rather have a woman who has an
opinion
only dogs are to obey if you truly love
your wife you will value her opinion
[Music]
can i talk to you for a second
what peanut who's your favorite
basketball player
magic johnson who's your favorite movie
star eddie murphy
who's your favorite rock star prince
[Music]
whatever happened to the good old days
oh
good old days these drinks
you know the days when men actually
flirted with him and asked you all for a
real date you know really high
then they're hiding they're too damn
scared to make a commitment
they were white women oh mary
they're ugly they behind bars
she was still convinced though that a
negro blood didn't matter
now that terrell couldn't use it to keep
the man she wanted to marry out of the
man's race
she was in love and couldn't see for
dreaming
any better than the rest of us i guess
because even though we had fought a war
to keep the world free
the color line in america work both ways
and even a rich white man like todd
carter
was afraid to cross it
hey
this old town can slow you down
people taking the easy way
but i know exactly where i'm
[Music]
but i don't care
[Music]
dear white people the minimum
requirement of black friends needed to
not seem racist has just been raised
to two sorry but your weed man
tyrone does not count
[Music]
he leaves
what's up i never hear that
and as you can see i am not dead
[Music]
i don't want to sound foolish
but remember love is what brought you
here
and if you trusted love this far
don't panic now trust it all the way
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you